bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv fil
78 si vous le rejoignez bien sûr pour un
nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés la
question que nous nous posons ce soir
comment accompagner les jeunes des
quartiers populaires vers l'emploi vous
pouvez poser toutes vos questions et
participer à l'émission via les réseaux
sociaux a stagné tuit société avec un
taux de chômage qui atteint parfois le
double de la moyenne nationale les
jeunes des quartiers populaires
rencontre plusieurs difficultés pour
trouver un premier emploi quelles en
sont les causes principales
déscolarisation manque de formation
mauvaise orientation scolaire ou tout
simplement contexte économique morose
quels sont les dispositifs existant qui
permettent aux jeunes de s'insérer dans
le monde du travail sont ils efficaces
et suffisamment connu autant de
questions auxquelles nous allons tenter
de répondre avec nos invités emmanuel
loevenbruck bon soir vous êtes coachs
professionnels certifiés et vous êtes
venu avec un jeune que vous accompagnez
miguel logiciel pour soir également
mehdi litim bonsoir diplômé de sciences
po en finance et stratégie fondateur
notamment du traspy blog dont on a déjà
parlé ici sur tv fils bonsoir nasser
jalal vous êtes responsable du point
information jeunesse de vernouillet bon
sens bonsoir
amara traoré enfin président de
l'association very emploi et je précise
que vous êtes adjoint aux sports pour la
ville de la verrière
bonsoir également merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation comme je le disais en
introduction le taux de chômage dans les
quartiers populaires est deux fois plus
importante que la moyenne nationale
dans ce premier graphique que je vous
propose de découvrir
eh bien nous avons une comparaison des
taux de chômage en 2012 on va
s'intéresser justement à la tranche
d'âge 15 à 24 ans et on peut remarquer
au niveau national il y à 23,1 pour cent
donc de taux de chômage alors que dans
les zones urbaines sensibles le taux de
chômage est de 45%
messieurs j'ai envie de vous demander
une première réaction peut-être sur
séché
phr et sur l'importance de ce chômage
dans les zones pour commencer oui on
voit une grande grande différence quand
même parce que entre des zones
privilégiées des zones de quartier
finalement la différence est encore plus
grande que ce qu'on voit sur le
graphique
donc on arrive à pas loin de 50 % pour
démarrer dans la vie ni dans la vie
professionnelle dans la vie adulte
c'est quand même un sujet qui va vous
avez pris le bon chiffre là on ne peut
que faire quelque chose on se dit qu'on
est dit les présidents avec 50% des voix
on arrive bientôt à 50% de deux jeunes
qui n'ont pas de travail et on se dit il
ya vraiment quelque chose à faire on est
là pour ça mais tout le monde doit se
remonter les manches les divisible ouais
en fait ce taux de chômage important
dans les zones urbaines sensibles
déjà il correspond au nombre de jeunes
qui se sont inscrits ou qui sont encore
inscrits au pôle emploi
donc du coup les chefs le chiffre est
encore plus important la reine et selon
l'insee le halo du chômage quand on
parle du chômage en france qui
correspond à 50% des chiffres officiels
donc si on est sur 45 % on peut
envisager que le chiffre réel et 20
points supérieure ça c'est lié trêve 1.6
et 50% le halo du chômage
quelqu'un selon les chiffres de l'insee
au niveau national si on est sur le même
type de chiffres
ce serait 20 points la moitié de ses 45
en gros de toute façon quand on quand on
quand on traîne un peu dans les
quartiers de temps en temps l'après midi
on se rend bien compte
alors peut-être moins en hiver que au
printemps on se rend bien compte qu'il
ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de jeunes
qui sont de temps en temps dans la rue
donc on se rend bien compte que ces
massifs
le deuxième élément c'est que c'est
important pour comprendre ce chiffre là
de ne pas dissocier ce qui se passe au
niveau du système scolaire et sur le
marché de l'emploi
parce que ces jeunes en fait qu'ils sont
massivement au chômage dans les zones
urbaines sensibles dans les banlieues
c'est des jeunes en fait qui sont en
grande partie des scolarisés
on viendra justement sur l'importance de
la déscolarisation dans dans ces
chiffres du chômage jeunes d'abord la
soeur janet sans excès heureusement ce
que disait mais dit on les voit
massivement airs et un peu un peu dans
les quartiers et cela ne sont inscrits
nulle pa donc après on n'a pas
véritablement de moyens pour les poules
pour les recenser mais c'est vrai
qu'après ça c'est vraiment au niveau
national il faut vraiment qu'on s'y
penche de plus près pour que c'est comme
ces critiques est ce que moi je
j'entends de la part des jeunes le plus
souvent c'est pour ceux qui sont
déscolarisés qu'ils ont eu lieu indique
qu'ils ont eu un décrochage scolaire
très près
le manque de formation donc il n'y a pas
assez de budget est ce qu'on entend
souvent n'y a pas assez de budget on
n'est pas pris en considération il ya
aussi le manque de confiance qui qui qui
se lit assez vrai que c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment là c'est vraiment
critiquer il faut vraiment trouver une
solution au bras traoré oui je rejoins
également ce qui a été dit par les
invités je pense que tout passe par
l'éducation
nous avons en france chaque année cent
cinquante huit jeunes qui quittent le
système scolaire ce qui est grand
diplôme sans qualification et donc ses
150 mille jeunes qui quittent le système
scolaire sans qualification
il va bien falloir qu'on s'en préoccupe
sérieusement pour éviter que tous les
ans on est un chômage qui ne cesse de
d'atteindre des sommets et
et après c'est aussi lié à la
compétitivité la compétitivité pardon
deux entreprises s'il ya un chômage qui
monte c'est que forcément les
entreprises perdent des parts de marché
qui à une concurrence qui s'installe et
16,25 directement impactés oui je veux
la chaire est moindre quand même voilà
certainement ce que je voulais aussi
dire c'est qu'on a aussi l'impression
qu'on a une fracture sociale dans notre
pays on voit bien quand dans des zones
urbaines sensibles on a parfois 60 70 %
de chômage et que dans d'autres
territoires on en a un peu moins on voit
bien que il ya une fracture qui
s'installait depuis quelques années dans
ce pays et il faut que nos politiques
réapproprient ces questions en lançant
mehdi d'abord et puis après très
rapidement il faut avoir bien entre l
inégalité de la situation sociale que
sur une zone d'emploi autour de
versailles versa et autour de versailles
on est sur un taux de chômage de 6 % et
est en gros on ne peut pas être en
dessous de 3 % de taux de chômage parce
que c'est le taux de chômage minimum
donc en gros on se rend compte que quand
on est né ou quand on a grandi quand on
est jeune sur versailles ou autour de
versailles
on a très peu de chances d'être chômage
et encore moins de manière durable
alors que quand on est et qu'on grandit
dans une zone urbaine sensible
en gros quand on a un emploi très
rapidement quand on est sortis de
l'école on est presque
c'est presque une rareté donc là on voit
bien qu'il ya un vrai problème de fond
parce que sur deux territoires qui sont
espacés de 15 km on a des situations
sociales qui sont totalement différentes
et ça c'est inacceptable
vous avez déjà abordé le problème de la
déscolarisation mais j'ai envie de dire
la déscolarisation une fois qu'on est
déscolarisé est-ce que c'est
rédhibitoire du coup qu'est ce qu'on
fait concrètement avec des déscolarisés
qui sont pas forcément en train de
traîner à l'extérieur mais mais qui ne
font plus à l'école surtout si c'est
difficile de les cibler c'est vrai qu'on
a faim on a pas on n'a pas véritablement
de moyens de
2 les six blessés c'est au bon vouloir
aussi des parents et du jeune en
question que si le jeune est mineur il
dépend de ses parents mais s'il est
majeur c'est vrai que c'est un peu
compliqué de de l'amener directement
vers les organismes appropriés comme
admettons le point le pij le point
information jeunesse
donc c'est vrai que c'est vraiment c'est
un peu compliqué pour pour les pour les
amener tu tu as pu voir emmanuel c'est
un peu compliqué pour les amener
directement mais une fois qu'ils sont
pris en charge
là on peut plus ou mois les recenser
mais sinon sans sens où on n'a pas
vraiment de de moyens alors justement
megal qui est qui est venu avec vous on
va voir ainsi la suivait aussi un petit
peu ce parcours alors vous avez 20 ans
et ça et vous allez suivre une formation
de serveurs et de barman alors quel
parcours scolaire vous avez vous avez
suivi mois en en seconde je suis parti
en vente
j'ai fait un an après j'ai vu par moi
même ça me plaisait pas j'ai arrêté
après suis parti voir la mission locale
bail pour tim oriente ils m'ont orienté
dans une formation puis après ils m'ont
orienté pour trouver un patron tout ça
en apprentissage dans le bâtiment
malheureusement j'ai fait mes deux ans
j'ai eu mon diplôme et samaa à cause de
mon allergie pas pu continuer avec
quelque chose qui vous plaisent et quand
même c'est un plaisir parce que je
voulais être décorateur mais
malheureusement à cause de mon âge et
pas que continue près pendant un an je
me suis mis j'ai travaillé dans la
distribution
et puis après pendant un an je me suis
mis avec je pars tu vois ramassèrent
pour voir mon projet pour
ouvrir pour voir ce qui se passe et je
vais par moi-même que c'était ce milieu
là et empreintes après j'ai travaillé
qu'une main serrée et me voici que j'ai
trouvé deux formations et quel a été le
travail du coup qui a été fait avec le
coach parce que ma soeur diana l'a
évoqué tout à l'heure un des problèmes
principaux grands contre les jeunes
notamment dans ces quartiers populaires
c'est le manque de confiance en soi donc
de confiance qui pour vous et la base de
tous les échecs qui peuvent être
rencontrées
alors qu'est-ce qu'il fait passer pour
clairement comment vous avez trop
travailler ensemble avec emmanuel valloy
moi moi en fait si je prends ma part
c'était le manque de confiance en moi et
le stress parce que j'étais stressée
envers un employeur quand j'allais voir
un employeur bas je panique et j'ai
bafouillé et il manque de confiance en
moi parce que des fois je n'étais pas
trop trop sûr de moi et après avec
emmanuel on a fait des exercices et j'ai
réussi à enlever mon stress et fois son
salaire simple vois ça a l'air fort tout
à fait et puis on le voit la mygale il
est pour la première fois à la
télévision
et puis il énonce ses difficultés il
pourra nous dire aussi ce qui n'a envie
ses rêves et ça a duré
c'est un coaching individuel comment ça
s'est passé le coaching pour donner des
aliments
on a eu cinq séances en tout trois
séances en collectif ses seins il était
5 6 4
des plans d un peu des jours et puis il
ya eu deux séances individuelles et
c'est à l'occasion d'une séance
individuelle
l'objectif de cette petite séance qu'on
a eue c'était pour pour toi un miel de
dire comment je fais j'ai un entretien
avec un patron d'un bar
j ça
j'ai peur voilà et puis on a pu jouer
cette scène sa voix là on a fait deux
fois et et puis voilà les appréhensions
on le voit aujourd'hui elles sont
parties donc c'est pas grand chose et
dans le coaching c'est ce qu'on cherche
à faire c'est de pas simplement
travailler comme on peut le faire à
l'école sur les compétences
on travaille sur les motivations travail
sur les valeurs ont travaillé sur les
moteurs on peut mettre des mots sur les
moteurs et quand on a ces mots-là en
tête mais on peut on peut avancer
alors ça c'est une des solutions qui
peut éventuellement être proposé c'est à
dire d'accompagner de jeunes mais
évidemment ceux qui nous regardent vont
se dire que dans les quartiers
populaires ce n'est pas uniquement une
question de confiance qui qui qui fait
que les gens ne vont pas de d'emploi ne
trouvent pas d'emploi question une
question de confiance mais de ce que je
vois des six qui étaient là pendant ces
séances il ya quand même beaucoup de ça
les eaux les trois objectifs qu'on
s'était donné avec l'action sociale
c'était s'affirmer dans un groupe
c'était préciser le projet professionnel
et puis commencer les démarches et enfin
savoir se présenter et ça collait bien
avec ce que attendait les jeunes
donc on voit bien que tout ça c'est pas
de leur tellement de la compétence a
tellement pas tellement de la formation
et que c'est quelque chose de g là
quelque chose qui démarre on travaille
avec des gens extérieurs de l'intérieur
c'est tout un réseau qui se met en place
où on laisse le jeune aussi très
autonome c'est lui qui prend en charge
son parcours et ça c'est important
amara traoré ou vous êtes président
comme on a dit en introduction very
emploi de l'association qui essaye de
mettre en lien des jeunes de la verrière
avec des entreprises locales notamment
alors on peut nous parler de la génèse
de ce projet et surtout nous dire est ce
que ça marche donc la genèse de ce
projet c'était il ya à peu près deux ans
des initiatives de
la ville une réunion avait été organisée
avec monsieur le maire et les habitants
du quartier du poil des temps dont je
suis habitants je précise et à cette
réunion les jeunes qui étaient présents
avec exprimé qu'il ne comprenait pas que
lorsqu'il faisait des démarches pour
avoir un stage ou chercher du boulot
tout simplement qu'il n'y avait pas de
il n'avait pas de retours positifs des
entreprises locales
même en faisant la fin même faisant la
démarche d'aller solliciter sa valeur et
donc après s'était posé la question de
savoir comment justement on peut se
serait peut-être bien d'organiser une
réunion ou un forum entre les jeunes du
quartier et ses entreprises pour qu il
ya une discussion
et donc si ce qui a été fait donc par la
ville et les jeunes gis étaient
également présents on nous avons
participé à l'élaboration de ce forum il
y avait à peu près 150 jeunes qui
avaient participé à ce forum
je crois que c'était le première pour la
ville de la verrière et donc à ce forum
les échanges a été assez riche à la fois
de la part des habitants du bois de
l'étang et des chefs d'entreprise qui
étaient présents qui ont joué le jeu et
donc les questions essentielles que les
gens posaient c'était est-ce que vous
avez des critères de
d'acceptation de cv ou et donc les
entreprises répondent est tout
simplement que non et s'était ouvert à
tous il y avait pas discrète 12e de
profil tout type de profil et donc après
vous créer cette association voilà donc
où on a voulu créer l'association pour
continuer cette dynamique et créer un
partenariat avec les entreprises locales
et dire aux entreprises mais écoutez il
se trouve qu'aujourd'hui la réalité
c'est que nos jeunes ont du mal à
franchir le pas vers l'entreprise parce
que il ya de manque de confiance on en
discute et tout à l'heure avec le jeune
parce qu'il ya des clichés des deux
côtés et donc nous on s'est dit que il
fallait inscrire en association pour
essayer de justement de prendre part
donc ça vous le faites vous faites
l'association en 2014
voilà sauf que n'a qu'un but les
caennais que we will concrètement il ya
une entreprise qui nous avait sollicités
et rechercher trois personnes pour une
mission au canada qui devait se dérouler
au mois de novembre 2015 et donc moi
j'avais envoyé trois cv donc vous êtes
allé voir les jeunes en disant voilà il
ya une opportunité tout à fait tout à
fait ce que vous avez dit à ce moment là
les jeunes ces jeunes là bas ils ont
expliqué que suite au forum qui avait eu
à l'initiative de vous et de la ville
une entreprise joue le jeu il ya un ils
ont ils vont avoir une mission au canada
il cherche des jeunes
donc est-ce que ça vous pourrez
éventuellement vous intéresser et donc
ils m'ont répondu oui donc moi j'ai
transmis hier quelques-uns étaient un
peu réticents
oui il ya des alliances oui c'est vrai
que j'ai oui on est toujours dans les
airs et oui mais je voudrais je pense
qu'ils vont pas me prend de l'asie mais
il n'y a pas de raison qu'ils vous
prennent pas donc faut pas être
défaitiste info il faut que l'optimiste
aussi l'optimisme à redon et donc
les semaines avancent et j'ai renoncé à
lancer pour savoir où s'arrêter et à
deux semaines du début du contrat je
reçois un mail de la drh ressources
humaines pardon qui m'explique
ils ont eu un problème avec un
fournisseur et que par rapp à quoi là et
que par conséquent ils ont recours à
l'intérim au jour le jour mais que les
cv que j'avais envoyé
il est gardé au chaud et le cas échéant
il s'appellerait si besoin
bon donc elles sont pour l'instant les
cv sont tout heureux
toujours à l'affût deux ans mais après
ce que je veux dire là c'est que voilà
c'est une réalité
c'est à dire que voilà on a en a les
paroles des actes et des paroles
s'envolent et ben heureusement nous on
est confronté un comment on explique ça
alors mes dix victimes puisque comme dit
amara traoré à l'instant des entreprises
qui s'installent par exemple à la
verrière dont les jeunes des quartiers
voit clairement que ces entreprises sont
sur leur de son de leur ville ou dans
leur communauté d'agglomération mais qui
n'empêche pas ces jeunes même quand il
ya une tentative de médiation soit de
devil ou d'associations qui se créent
mais en fait il ya deux facteurs
mais on a du mal à voir quelle est
l'importance de chacun de ces facteurs
il ya un problème de discrimination ou
de manière générale de peur parce que la
discrimination de la part des chefs
d'entreprise c'est une peur que le
comportement du jeune ne soit pas adapté
alors déjà aux nécessités de
l'entreprise de son activité économique
mais aussi c'est un problème de peur de
de défaut d'intégration du jeune qui
vient du quartier dans les équipes de
l'entreprise mais il faut je pense qu'il
faut pas même si il faut lutter contre
ça il faut pas expliqué le chômage dans
les quartiers et uniquement par sa ouais
je pense même que par rapport à l'autre
phénomène qui est l'échec scolaire et du
coup l'absence de compétences
académiques technique
et beaucoup plus que la discrimination
c'est marginal par rapport aux chiffres
qu'on a entendu tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs pour préciser aussi on voit
un autre graphique à l'instant avec
l'augmentation du taux de chômage entre
2003 et 2012 et on le voit dans les
zones emerson
ils ont les organes sociaux par an il a
augmenté alors que quand on voit le la
petite courbe en dessous qui est un
représente la moyenne nationale
elle est entre 8 et 10 alors que de
l'autre côté on les passait jusqu'à
jusqu'à plus de 20% alors en fait du
coup on a quand même un trop grand
nombre de jeunes dans les banlieues mais
c'est pas que dans les brevets dans les
banlieues c'est aussi dans le nord de la
france et c'est aussi dans le sud est de
la france
on a trop de jeunes en fait qui sortent
du système scolaire sans diplôme
donc 140 à 150 milles ça correspond à
17% 17% de deux jeunes qui sont nés une
une année 17% sortent sans aucun diplôme
donc là dans une économie comme la nôtre
c'est juste c'est juste pas possible
et quand on est touché par une crise
économique et ses réguliers je veux dire
on a eu 93 on a eu 2000 on a eu de 2008
eh ben les populations qui vont être les
plus touchés par la hausse du chômage
eh ben ça va être les jeunes partout en
france et ça va être les jeunes d'autant
plus qu' ils sont moins bien formés
donc tous les contrats en cdd tous les
contrats en intérim sont sucrés en
premier par les entreprises et qui sont
qui est en intérim qui est en cdd et ben
pas uniquement mais massivement des
jeunes qui ont des diplômes soient qui
sont assez peu demandés soit qu'ils
n'ont pas de diplôme et du coup c'est ce
qui va expliquer que quand on a une
augmentation du chômage
on va voir la courbe du chômage des
jeunes dans les zones urbaines sensibles
mais c'est pareil dans le nord de la
france et dans le sud est qui va qui va
exploser
alors vous miguel autour de vous à des
jeunes qui ont entre 19 20 21 ans
est ce que la plupart sont en recherche
d'emploi est ce que beaucoup également
ont des diplômes ou pas j'ai moi j'ai
beaucoup d'amis à moi ils ont des
diplômes sans recherche d'emploi mais
malheureusement et trouve pas après il
ya beaucoup de
comme disait c'est un beaucoup de
patrons comme tu habites dans un
quartier d'ain et bryce disent que c'est
pas une personne agréable pour notre
entreprise et vous arrivez comme à aller
malgré ça quand on dit que vous venez de
tels quartiers par exemple vous arrivez
à aller jusqu'à l'entretien avec le
patron ou est-ce que des fois il ya la
barrière et puis après on leur demandera
aussi à 1 a servi à langnau sama arrivé
que j'arrivais devant d'entretien et je
voyais que je ressentais que la personne
a été réticent et ça m'arrivait aussi
que je posais des cv qu'un ami excusez
moi du terme est aisé d'y poser un cv et
qu'il a eu un entretien et que moi j'en
avais pas et parce que voilà
c'est malheureux à dire mais c'est la
vérité l'infernal sait des choses que
vous aurez enfin je le rencontre puisque
j'ai mon petit réseau personnel avec les
entreprises et je suis obligé de me
porter garant en tant que
nasser jalal pour vraiment dire que cela
il exerça il est intégré le pij
il est assidu et à partir de là
mutuellement il ya un entretien qui est
qui qui émet en place et c'est
malheureux qu'on en arrive là parce que
certains certaines entreprises ne jouent
pas le jeu du tout ils sont catégoriques
et ils ne disent pas franchement mais on
comprend bien que le jeune venant du
d'un quartier populaire c'est
catégorique donc on lui donne pas sa
chance malgré qu'il a des diplômes on
parle de ce qu'ils ont des diplômes des
non diplômés et diplômées bien sûr mais
l'origine du quartier fait que ça joue
énormément et comme je vous disais tout
à l'heure je suis obligé de me porter
garant ça va ça marche ça marche et il
ya un suivi aussi des airs donc
finalement si le jeune en question ne
jouent pas le jeu je suis en lien direct
avec avec les responsables des
entreprises donc quelque part aussi le
jeune il est obligé m'a déjà dans un
premier temps quand il franchit le pas
au sein du pis et qu' il y là il a
commencé déjà sa démarche vers vers le
vers un retour à l'emploi
et ils jouent ils jouent complètement il
ya des résultats qui sont positifs et
mais voilà c'est vraiment une petite
goutte d'eau dans l'océan mais on reste
quand même optimiste
est ce qu'il ya des dispositifs qui sont
un peu méconnu des jeunes moi je pense
qu'ils sont peut-être pas faim
ils sont pas perceptibles je pense il ya
énormément dispositifs qui sont liées à
l'aide à la formation à l'emploi à tout
ce qu'on veut mais à mon avis le
problème c'est que c'est pas assez on a
vraiment être dedans pour avoir une
visibilité mais pour une personne
qui a quitté l'école il ya deux ans
enfin je sais pas moi je pense que c'est
c'est trop compliqué pour pour eux deux
et il ya aussi une défiance dire par ce
moment où on est déscolarisé je pense
qu'on n'a plus confiance en
l'institution se replie en un mot de
conclusion peut-être rapidement pour
dire voilà faire un peu de politique
ce que vous pensez que on va dans le bon
sens pourrait essayer de créer de
l'emploi que des trous à la de sortir un
petit peu ces jeunes car 45 % contre 23
%
enfin leur en faire des efforts et
maintenant ils vont pour complet j'ai
entendu nasser dire je me porte garant
est en fait j'aimerais bien lui demander
quel c'est quoi les trois critères si on
a trois qui fait qu' il donne sa
garantie des sraghna en tant que
responsable du point information
jeunesse
ça apporte déjà un tir et un petit plus
à cette garantie est en gros en gros
c'est voilà on fait du forcing vraiment
pour pour pour pousser la société a joué
le jeu et les trois critères qui font
que tu dis celui là je te garantis de la
connaissance et la connaissent
personnelle des gens qui ont appris les
temps on établit déjà des rendez vous au
préalable et à partir de là je ne sais
pas au premier rendez vous je recommande
directement le jeune en question c'est
vraiment voilà faut qu'une certaine
acidité qui respecte et tout au long ça
peut durer comme j'expliquais terme et
dit ça peut durer un mois une semaine un
mois un an mais à partir du moment où je
sens que le jeu n'est prêt là je peux je
peux préserver la race et c'est la
conclusion me dit victime peut-être sur
justement cette politique qui est fait
actuellement est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui est ce que vous êtes
pessimiste plutôt optimiste pour la
suite mais je ne suis pas je suis pas
optimiste malheureusement parce que on
sait que l'échec scolaire en fait il est
massif
surtout dans les quartiers populaires
depuis de nombreuses années et il n'ya
aucune politique suffisamment traité
voilà
et puis au niveau macroéconomique les
chiffres de la croissance sont positifs
mais ils sont pas suffisants pour créer
des emplois vous regarde un facteur du
contexte économique aussi globale et
voilà les deux là du coup merci en tout
cas tous les cinq d'avoir participé à
cette émission merci de miguel d'être
déplacés également pour nous parler de
ton parcours
je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
retrouver les missions sur les sites de
la télé tv fil 78 points comme et vous
pouvez également réagir sur le twitter
hashtag société on se retrouve le mois
prochain pour un nouveau numéro
bonne soirée